de ni pro C'est dans le sud-est du pays
où se trouve l'envoyée spéciale de
France 24 Mélina Huet bonjour Mélina
alors on voit que les forces
ukrainiennes continuent de regagner du
terrain depuis le début de la semaine
notamment dans la région de Louhans mais
aussi plus au sud vers Carson
oui tout à fait et vous l'avez dit nous
nous trouvons actuellement à ni pro je
me trouve précisément devant le fleuve
nèbre du même nom qui est l'un des plus
grands fleuves d'Europe et qui est très
stratégique dans cette guerre qui se
déroule en ce moment en Ukraine qui se
jette dans la mer Noire et qui passe par
repson dont vous avez parlé alors
effectivement la contre-offensive se
poursuit dans plusieurs des quatre
oblates qui ont été récemment annexés
par la Russie il faut savoir que dans
l'aublace de Ralph qui fin qui est qui
n'a pas été annexée par la Russie mais
qui a été occupé pour partie par les
forces armées russes et bien la
quasi-totalité de cette région est
désormais sous contrôle
ukrainien vous avez parlé de louant
c'est intéressant pourquoi parce que
c'est le seul oblat sur les quatre qui
ont été annexés qui a été entièrement
contrôlée à un moment donné par les
forces armées russes et qui aujourd'hui
est en train d'être grignoté dans cette
contre-offensive donc dont on parle
depuis la fin de l'été par les forces
armées ukrainiennes il y a eu pas moins
de six municipalités reprises hier selon
une allocution
de la ville de Helson qui est très
stratégique puisqu'on le rappelle elle a
été l'une des premières la première
grande ville prise par les Russie il
faut le dire sans vraiment de
difficultés en mars dernier en tout cas
il faut faire vite pour ses forces
armées ukrainiennes car à s'approche
dangereusement ce qu'on appelle ici la
race Poutine ça c'est une période à
l'automne où et bien il y a beaucoup de
pluie beaucoup de Gadoux et où les chars
et les blindés risques de sanglier
dangereusement
Mélina bonjour il y a ce sujet
d'inquiétude pour la communauté
internationale il s'agit de la centrale
de zapporizia qui est devenu la
propriété de la Russie hier Vladimir
Poutine la déclaré dans un décret à
signer un décret Raphaël grossit lui le
chef de la de l'IA est attendu
aujourd'hui à Kiev
oui tout à fait un sujet de
préoccupation depuis plusieurs mois
Pauline ce n'est pas un récent à tout
l'été la centrale de apollindia était au
cœur de cet inquiétude de la communauté
internationale sur un risque de
catastrophe nucléaire Rafael grossit
n'en est pas à sa première visite il est
passé à cet été avec des équipes de
l'UEA et il est resté plusieurs jours
pour déterminer si oui ou non il y avait
des fuites radioactifs dans cette
centrale la plus grande centrale en tout
cas la plus puissante centrale nucléaire
de Rome donc il est attendu à qui on ne
sait pas à ce stade s'il va pouvoir se
rendre directement
asapolijah dans dans cette oblase qui
est en partie occupée par la Russie donc
et vous l'avez dit Vladimir Poutine qui
a également signé un décret
officialisant que cette centrale
nucléaire appartenait à la Russie c'est
bien le seul sur la communauté
internationale et bien à à dire que
cette centrale nucléaire est russe on
rappelle qu'elle est toujours elle est
toujours mise en opération par des
populations locales l'Ukrainienne qui
sont sous contrôle russe cette centrale
nucléaire qui qui fait beaucoup de bruit
parce que il y a des frappes répétées
depuis plusieurs semaines dans sa
culotte mutuellement la Russie et
l'Ukraine est-ce que demain
conjointement avec l'ONU c'est la
démilitarisation de la zone depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant merci Mélina
vous étiez en direct de